it was my third day on the job at a hot
Silicon Valley startup in early 2013 I
was twice the age of the dozen engineers
in the room I've been brought into the
company because I was a seasoned expert
in my field but in this particular room
I felt like a new be amongst the tech
geniuses I was listening to them talk
and thinking that the best thing I could
do was be invisible and then suddenly
the 25-year old wizard leaving the
meeting stared at me and asked if you
shipped a feature and no one used it did
it really ship ship a feature in that
moment chip knew he was in deep ship I
had no idea what he was talking about I
just sat there awkwardly and mercifully
he moved on to someone else I slid down
in my chair and I couldn't wait for that
meeting to end that was my introduction
to Airbnb I was asked and invited by the
three millennial co-founders to join
their company to help them take their
fast-growing tech startup and turn it
into a global hospitality brand as well
as to be the in-house mentor for CEO
Brian Chesky now I'd spent from age 26
to 50 to being a boutique hotel
entrepreneur and so I guess had learned
a few things along the way and
accumulated some hospitality knowledge
but after my first week I realized that
the brave new home sharing world didn't
need much of my old-school bricks and
mortar hotel insights a stark reality
rocked me what do I have to offer I
don't I've never been in a tech company
before five and a half years ago I had
never heard of the sharing economy nor
did I have an uber or lyft app on my
phone this was not my natural habitat
so I decided at that moment that I could
either run for the hills or cast
judgment on these young geniuses or
instead turn the judgment into curiosity
and actually see if I could match my
wise eyes with their fresh eyes I
fancied myself a modern Margaret Mead
amongst the Millennials and I quickly
learned that I had as much to offer them
as they did to me the more I have seen
and learned about our respective
generations the more I realized that we
often don't trust each other enough to
actually share our respective wisdom we
may share a border but we don't
necessarily trust each other enough to
share that respective wisdom I believe
looking at the modern workplace the that
trade agreement of our time is opening
up these intergenerational pipelines of
wisdom so that we can all learn from
each other 40% of us almost 40% of us in
this unit in the United States have a
boss that's younger than us and that
number is growing quickly power is
cascading to the young like never before
because of our increasing reliance on DQ
digital intelligence we're seeing young
founders of companies in their early 20s
scale them up to global Giants by the
time they get to 30 and yet we expect
these young digital leaders to somehow
miraculously embody the relationship
wisdoms we older workers have had
decades to learn it's hard to microwave
your emotional intelligence there's
ample evidence that gender and
ethnically diverse companies are more
effective but what about age this is a
very important question because for the
first time ever we have five generations
in the workplace at the same time
unintentionally maybe it's time they got
a little bit more intentional about how
we worked collectively there have been a
number of European studies that have
that age diverse teams are more
effective and successful so why is it
that only 8% of the companies that I
have had that have a diversity and
inclusion program have actually expanded
that strategy to include aged as just as
important of a demographic as gender or
race maybe they didn't get the memo
the world is getting older one of the
paradoxes of our time is that baby
boomers are more vibrant and healthy
longer into life we're actually working
later into life and yet we're feeling
less and less relevant some of us feel
like a carton of milk an old carton of
milk
with an expiration date stamped on our
wrinkled foreheads for many of us in
midlife this isn't just a feeling it is
a harsh reality when we suddenly lose
our job and the phone stops ringing for
many of us justifiably we worry that
people see our experience as a liability
not an asset you've heard of the old
phrase or maybe the relatively new
phrase 60 is the new 40 physically right
when it comes to power in the workplace
today 30 is the new 50 all right well
this is all pretty exciting right
truthfully power is moving 10 years
younger we're all gonna live 10 years
longer do the math Society has created a
new 20 year irrelevance egapp midlife
used to be 45 to 65 but I would suggest
it now stretches into a midlife marathon
40 years long from 35 to 75 but wait
there is a bright spot why is it that we
actually get smarter and wiser about our
humanity as we age our physical peak
maybe our 20s our financial and salary
peak maybe age 50 but our emotional
appeal is in midlife and Beyond because
we have developed pattern recognition
about ourselves and others so how can we
get companies to tap into that wisdom
of the midlife folks just as they
nurture their digital young geniuses as
well the most successful companies today
and in the future will actually learn
how to create a powerful alchemy of the
two here's how the alchemy worked for me
at Airbnb I was assigned a young smart
partner who helped me develop a DeVos
pettalia Department early on
Laura Hughes could see that I was a
little lost in this habitat so she often
sat right next to me in meetings so she
could be my tech translator and I could
write her notes and she could tell me
that's what that means
Laura was 27 years old she worked for
Google for four years and then for a
year and a half at Airbnb when I met her
like many millennial Co of her cohorts
she had actually grown into a managerial
role before she'd gotten any formal
leadership training I don't care if
you're in the b2b world the b2c world
the CSE world or the A to Z world
business is fundamentally h2h human to
human and yet
Laura's approach to leadership was
really formed in the technocratic world
and it was purely metric driven one of
the things she said to me in the first
few months is I love the fact that your
approach to leadership is to create a
compelling vision that becomes a North
Star for us now my fact knowledge as in
how many rooms a maid cleans in an
eight-hour shift might not be all that
important in a Home Sharing world my
process knowledge of how do you get
things done based upon understanding the
underlying motivations of everybody in
the room was incredibly valuable in a
company where most people didn't have a
lot of organizational experience as I
spent more time at Airbnb I realized
it's possible a new kind of elder was
emerging in the workplace not the elder
of the past who actually was regarded
with reverence know what is striking
about the modern elder is their
relevance their ability to use timeless
wisdom and apply it to modern day
problems
maybe it's time we actually valued
wisdom as much as we do disruption and
maybe it's time not just maybe it is
time for us to definitely reclaim the
word elder and give it a modern twist
the modern elder is as much an intern as
they are a mentor because they realize
in a world that is changing so quickly
their beginner's mind and their
catalytic curiosity is a life-affirming
elixir not just for themselves but for
everyone around them
intergenerational improv has been known
in music and the arts think Tony Bennett
and Lady Gaga or Wynton Marsalis and the
young stars of jazz this kind of
business this kind of riffing in the
business world is often called mutual
mentorship millennial dq4 Gen X and
Boomer EQ I got to experience that kind
of intergenerational reciprocity with
Laura and our stellar data science team
when we were actually remaking and
evolving the Airbnb peer to peer review
system using Laura's analytical mind and
my human centered intuition with that
perfect alchemy of algorithm and people
wisdom we were able to create an
instantaneous feedback feedback loop
that helped our hosts better understand
the needs of our guests high tech meets
high touch at Airbnb I also learned as a
modern elder that my role was to intern
publicly and mentor privately search
engines are brilliant giving you an
answer but a wise sage guide can
actually can offer you just the right
question Google does not understand at
least not yet nuance like a finely
attuned human heart and mind over time
to my surprise dozens and dozens of
young employees that Airbnb sought me
out for private mentoring sessions but
in reality we were offering off
just mentoring each other in some CEO
Brian Chesky brought me in for my
industry knowledge but what I really
offered was my well-earned wisdom maybe
it's time we retire the term knowledge
worker and replaced it with wisdom or
cur we have five generations in the
workplace today and we can operate like
separate isolationist countries or we
can actually start to find a way to
bridge these generational borders and
it's time for us to actually look at how
to change up the physics of wisdom so it
actually flows in both directions from
old to young and from young to old how
can you apply this in your own life
personally who can you reach out to to
create a mutual mentorship relationship
and organizationally how can you create
the conditions to foster an
intergenerational flow of wisdom this is
the new sharing economy thank you
[Applause]